[Musik]
dazu ist niedersachsen sieht an sich aus
wie die cdu gegen weil sie damit der
film an den rändern bröckelt es und
allmählich wird auch alles so ein
bisschen braun
sondern hier ja weder land von der spd
regiert überall gibt's quotenfrau und
hier die rotunde mit dem piercing dann
ist die gleichstellungsbeauftragte von
der ganzen horde
[Musik]
als ob die spd nicht so schlimm genug
wäre gibt es hierzu wörtlich auch noch
die grünen mit ihren bekloppten idee
kommen wieder keiner vorbei
der wolf ist ein scheues tier weil er
aber zu viel frisst und auch rotkäppchen
im waldkindergarten erschreckt wie die
cdu jetzt rudelweise abknallen er wird
für die ard natürlich schwer noch einen
drauf zu satteln
wie wärs mit wolfswelpen erhöhen sondern
auch keine parteien programm am sonntag
wieder nämlich gewählt wieso fragst du
isst ja auch referendum würde ich
niedersachsen abspalten von deutschland
zu früh gefreut
[Musik]
die haltung gibt es quasi gar nicht mehr
sei die grünen regierung sind das ist
angela legehenne des monats september
da machen die sterbebegleitung zum
schlachthof sie hat sogar eine
patientenverfügung als zu unterzeichnen
bei der wahl geht es natürlich um
inhalte zb wie viel nitrat gehört ins
trinkwasser damit noch original
niedersächsisch mädchen
ich würde sagen südoldenburger
weißherbst und güllefass aufgebaut das
in kothen abgang
[Musik]
so jetzt reist wir kleine schöne kuba
damit der onkel laur am sonntag nun im
topf hat wunder bleiben
[Musik]
[Applaus]